[Musik]
herr gas die maßnahmen der pandemie die
greifen nicht sagen die
intensivmediziner seit mitte märz sind
unterm strich 1000 intensivpatienten
zusätzlich in den krankenhäusern
gelandet und intensivmediziner fordern
jetzt verpflichtende tests an schulen
zwei mal pro woche mehr tempo beim
impfen und vor allem einen zweiwöchigen
locker und schließen sie sich diesen
forderungen an
vieles von dem was von den
intensivmediziner gefordert wird ist ja
eigentlich auf den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen längst beschlossen worden
wir haben dort erlebt dass beim
vorletzten mal die notbremse beschlossen
wurde
sie wird nur nicht konsequent umgesetzt
das ist der punkt und ich glaube stadt
immer wieder neue maßnahmen zu
beschließen die dann nicht umgesetzt
werden wäre es gut wenn die politik eine
klare strategie hat und das in allen
bundesländer auch einheitlich gehandelt
wird es ist natürlich nicht sehr
glaubwürdig wenn das eine bundesland
sich komplett zum modellversuch erklärt
und ein anderer ministerpräsident vor
incidents zahlen von 700 waren das
verunsichert die menschen und führt
natürlich nicht zu konsequentem handeln
was halten sie von diesen
modellprojekten wie sie zum beispiel
auch im saarland jetzt nach ostern
geplant sind ist jetzt eigentlich die
zeit für solche modellprojekte die
incidents werte steigen die
infektionszahlen steigen sollte man so
etwas nicht lieber auf einen anderen
zeitpunkt verlegen wenn vielleicht die
werte stabil sind oder sogar senken
sinken
ja der meinung bin ich ich halte es
nicht für sinnvoll jetzt ein ganzes
bundesland zum modellversuch zu erklären
denn modellversuche sollen ja in
beispielsweise städten kleineren städten
und in einem überschaubaren setting dann
tatsächlich wissenschaftlich begleitet
werden können um dann daraus die
richtigen schlüsse zu ziehen
ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
wie das in einem ganzen bundesland
passiert soll und deswegen lehnen wir
derartige möglichkeiten und projekte ab
wie ist denn die situation momentan auf
den intensivstationen stand dienstag
waren es glaube ich 3200
intensivpatienten und die aktuellen
infektionszahlen die schlagen sich ja
immer erst 14 tage später auf den infekt
auf den intensivstationen nieder
ja wir haben seit mehreren wochen
kontinuierlich steigende zahlen wir
legen heute morgen bei gut 3600 das
zeigt die zahl die sie genannt haben ist
schon wieder angestiegen in den letzten
tagen und sie wird auch in den kommenden
tagen ansteigen wie wir ein
kontinuierliches anwachsen haben
das ist die situation insofern ist die
lage ernst und sie haben es in ihrem
bericht auch gezeigt die mitarbeiter
werden und mitarbeiter sind jetzt im
prinzip seit einem jahr fast im
ausnahmezustand
im sommer gab es mal eine kleine
atempause aber seitdem sind hier im
ausnahmezustand und wir alle hoffen
natürlich darauf dass die positiven
gegenläufigen trends die durch die
impfung endlich wirken sollen und wirken
müssen dann im monat mai juni juli zu
einer gewissen entlastung auch für die
lage ist ernst sagen sie und könnte ja
auch noch ernster werden eben mit dieser
14-tägigen verschiebung der verband der
intensivmediziner sagt man könnt ihr
könnten bald sechs bis siebentausend
intensivpatienten haben weil wir eben
momentan noch in einem exponentiellen
wachstum sind dann wäre das system
überlastet oder es ist in der tat nicht
auszuschließen dass wir auf sechs oder
sieben 1000 intensivpatienten kommen in
den nächsten wochen dann liegen wir etwa
auf dem niveau der spitzen wie das
spitzen jetzt der zweiten welle dort
hatten wir knapp 6000 belegte betten
wir haben damals nicht die totale
überlastung erlebt und wir werden sie
nach meiner einschätzung auch diesmal
bei diesen zahlen nicht erleben denn wir
haben auch hier einen durchaus positiven
effekt unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter die noch in der zweiten
welle vielfach von quarantänemaßnahmen
und von eigener infektiosität betroffen
waren sind fast durchgehend geimpft das
heißt das personal steht uns in größerem
umfang zur verfügung wir rechnen nicht
mit so großen personalausfällen das gibt
mir zuversicht aber die lage ist ernst
das ist so
ich würde gern noch einmal mit ihnen
über die impfkampagne
stand sprechen sie fordern seit langem
nicht erst seit der geänderten
altersgrenze für astrazeneca eine andere
impfstrategie was macht deutschland
falsch beim impfen
der erste punkt ist nach unserer
auffassung wir müssen sehr viel mehr
engagement
die erstimpfung legen wir müssen
wirklich den zeitraum die zeitspanne
zwischen erst und zweikämpfen maximal
ausschöpfen das haben uns beispielsweise
auch die briten vor gemacht denn mit der
erstimpfung können wir schon einen
relativ guten schutz in der bevölkerung
erreichen und das ist in der summe dann
deutlich vorteilhafter und entlastet
auch die krankenhäuser ist das erste und
das zweite die situation jetzt mit im
astra impfstoff der nur noch für über 60
jährige zugelassen werden soll es
natürlich um gut und verunsichert die
menschen deswegen ist unsere forderung
jetzt ganz klar wir müssen jetzt mit
diesen impfstoff in die arztpraxen denn
es wird einige geben die ihre termine
nicht mehr wahrnehmen wollen auch von
den über 60-jährigen da ist dann das
nachimpfen durch andere die nicht auf
der terminliste stehen in den arztpraxen
viel einfacher als eine relativ
schwerfällige neue terminvergabe an neue
personen über die zentralen in zentren